is Alex kurtzman about to get fired by
Paramount and does this mean the end of
new track
the rumors arrive
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
so a couple of sources that have come to
me are saying and these are not rumors
let's be honest that Alex kurtzman is
about to be fired by Paramount now he
has a contract that runs till 2026 but
he actually has a couple of contracts
running with Paramount and one to do
with Star Trek want to do with other
projects the one that runs to 2026 is
more to do with the other projects and
that has a lot of providers in it that
are going to allow Paramount to release
him from that but the contract that
actually we're more interested in runs
out quite soon and paramounts are not
going to renew according to a source
that I've been speaking to they fully
intend to allow Alex kurtzman to leave
and that could be within the next two
months apparently there are elements to
that contract which means if he leaves
quietly you get a decent payout and then
he will actually be tied from speaking
about internal working of Paramount for
a certain period of time after that this
is a contract that is quite common we
see with football managers and stuff
football managers never slag off the old
managers and the old team until two
years after they get fired because it's
in their contract they're not allowed to
big CEOs and big Executives have similar
non-disclosure agreements and it's all
built into their payouts when they leave
or get fired Sonic Christmas isn't
really getting sacked his contract is
coming to an end and they're not going
to renew it but he is effectively
getting sacked because Paramount he is
the head man of Star Trek so if they do
not renew that contract but continue
with Star Trek they're going to have to
replace him but are they going to
continue with Star Trek this is another
point so my sources actually come to me
and said that this is a lot to do with
the stock price of Paramount it has
actually been steadily dropping for the
last 12 months and has continued to also
subscriptions for Paramount Plus have
not exactly met hopes and has been
struggling a little bit here in the UK
it's only actually been on our screens
for about six months you can actually
get it through broker subscriptions
which is apparently not done great or
here through Sky TV they actually have a
deal where if you get Sky Cinema which
is their sort of like Movie Channel you
get Paramount Plus for free that has
artificially increased the numbers of
Paramount prescriptions when it first
came out and made it look like it was
actually doing very well here in Europe
when in fact it wasn't actually bringing
in a lot of money so the rumor is the
Paramount might actually be in some
Financial stuck but one thing it owns
that it might be able to get rid of is
Star Trek now they have a couple of
options one is potentially they could
reset track and go back to pre-new track
and reset everything and bring us a new
Star Trek that is more familiar with
what ended at the end of sort of Deep
Space Nine Voyager type thing Picard
series one two and three might fit in
there
but Discovery and possibly even strange
new worlds which would be very strange
for me if true because I think that's
done very well I was actually a really
good first series I would be canceled
and ignored right so what do I actually
think about this
for one if they were going to get rid of
Alex kurtzman now is kind of a good time
to do it Discovery season five is about
to come out I would be surprised if we
got a season six the Picard seasons have
been so far a massive letdown but we
know that season three is the last one
of those
Picard series generally has not done
particularly well and has been quite
expensive to make more than 11 12
million dollars an episode Picard has
not just been expensive it's also been
critically and quite roundly panned and
a lot of the trekkies haven't
particularly liked it either
so Discovery could be ending Picard is
100 ending strange new world has just
had its second season but it has not
been renewed yet for a third now I would
be flabbergasted if they cancel strange
new rules the first season did very very
well as far as I'm aware I personally
loved it I cannot wait for the second
season and I know fans are desperate for
a third but I actually think the reason
why they haven't renewed officially is
third season yet is possibly because
they are looking to change the top man
it would make sense that if you are
changing the guard that this is actually
kind of the right time to do it we're in
a bit of a lull trackwise they are
potentially looking at several new
projects for Star Trek but it is quite
unusual that a lot of the projects we've
had rumored for several years have not
been announced like section 31 Michelle
yo this was 12 18 months ago pretty much
nailed on to be happening but it has
isn't is that because Paramount bosses
have been very unhappy with Alex Curtis
for some time and the reason why these
shows haven't been pushed forward is
because of things like the failure of
Picard and the general lackluster
performance of Discovery maybe they have
had enough of their top man and are
planning to change the guard
or maybe it's a little bit more than
that the paramounts are actually in
serious financial trouble and one thing
that they own which might actually hold
some value is the intellectual property
of Star Trek perhaps the plan is to sell
intellectual property to a third party
somebody they'll then come in and make a
new Star Trek for Paramount rather than
Paramount making it themselves
I don't know that I am speculating but
this rumor that's come to me
I just more I think about it the more I
think that if they were going to Alex
kurtzman that now would be the time but
there's a big if on this one it's not
been confirmed as far as I can tell I
haven't seen any major rumors about it
but what I can tell you is that Alex
kurtzman getting fired has been rumored
a lot over the last three or four years
and you have to argue that maybe there
is a smoke out fire and that if it
wasn't for the pandemic maybe you'd have
been sacked two or three years ago now I
would also say that the Animated Series
to for me are some of the best Star Trek
going Prodigy is fantastic and I've just
seen the season finale of lower decks I
love that show so much when it's good
lower decks is honestly the best Star
Trek on TV right now it's fantastic I
know it's got the silly humor I know
it's a cartoon but when it's good like
at the end of episode 10 and the end of
episode nine God it's good it's like
proper track I I love the spaceships and
I love all that I love the Space Battles
and things so for me that's just like oh
it's Star Trek porn it's awesome now
those projects don't necessarily come
under Alex kurtzman's Reign and wouldn't
really make any difference if he left
they'd keep McMahon on and he would
continue doing lower decks and Prodigy
would continue under Nickelodeon so no
problem there I actually just think that
Alex kurtzman if he is leaving now is
not a bad time to push the reset button
on a few of the projects I haven't done
as well but continue with a new
direction of the projects that have done
a bit better like strange new worlds and
the Animated Series completely separate
but guys get into the comments tell me
what you think is this good news if true
or do you actually not care
I'd love to know exactly what you think
if you're new to the Channel please like
subscribe hit that Bell notification it
really helps us out and if you enjoy the
content please consider hitting the join
button because that really supports the
channel as always please live long and
profit now stay safe and I'll see you
next time
[Music]